D
GIVE INTO INTERNAL PRESSURES.
>> A NEW RIGHT-WING GOVERNMENT
IS TAKING SHAPE IN ISRAEL, AS
FINAL ELECTION RESULTS
CONFIRMED BENJAMIN NETANYAHU
WILL BE RETURNING TO POWER.
THE CURRENT PRIME MINISTER,
YAIR LAPID, CONCEDED DEFEAT A
FEW HOURS AGO, CALLING TO
CONGRATULATE NETANYAHU.
THE FORMER PRIME MINISTER WILL
SERVE AN UNPRECEDENTED SIXTH
TERM.
A FAR-RIGHT ALLIANCE HELPED
NETANYAHU'S COALITION WON A
MAJORITY OF SEATS IN
PARLIAMENT.
NOW THOSE EXTREMIST ALLIES ARE
PUSHING FOR KEY GOVERNMENT
RULES.
ONE OF THOSE ALLIES, ITAMAR BEN
GVIR, WANTS TO BE PUT IN CHARGE
OF POLICE.
HE SUPPORTS RELAXING OPENED
FIRE --
AGAINST PALESTINIAN RIOTERS AND
WANTS SECURITY FORCES TO BE
IMMUNE FROM CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
AS HADAS GOLD REPORTS, THEN
GIVE YOUR HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
INCITING ANTI PALESTINIAN
HATRED.
>> UNTIL RECENTLY, THIS MAN,
ITAMAR WAS BEN GVIR, CONSIDERED
A FRINGE FAR-RIGHT ACTIVIST
SETTLER LAWYER.
HIS SIGNATURE WHITE KIPPAH,
ALMOST ALWAYS ASK YOU ON HIS
HEAD.
NOW A LEADER OF THE PROJECTED
THIRD LARGEST BLOCK IN THE
ISRAELI PARLIAMENT.
SAID TO BE A KEY COMPONENT OF
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU'S NOT LIKELY
COME BACK AS PRIME MINISTER.
THE 46-YEAR-OLD HAS BEEN A
PROVOCATEURS SINCE HIS YOUTH.
ONCE A SUPPORTER OF THE JEWISH
NATIONALISTS --
DEEMED TERRORIST ORGANIZATION
BY THE UNITED STATES AND
ULTIMATELY OUTLAWED BY ISRAEL.
HE WAS ONCE FILMED HOLDING A
HOOD EMBLEM HE CLAIMED WAS FROM
A CAR OF A FORMER ISRAELI PRIME
MINISTER, AN ARCHITECT AT THE
ISRAELI AND PALESTINIAN PEACE
PROCESS, VOWING WE GOT TO HIS
CAR AND WE'LL GET TO HIM TO.
A JEWISH EXTREMISTS
ASSASSINATED REDEEM DUE WEEKS
LATER.
EXCEPT FOR THE MILITARY DRAFT,
HE SAYS HE WAS DENIED FOR HIS
POLITICAL VIEWS, ITAMAR
BEN-GVIR SO HE BECAME A LAWYER,
--
FAMOUSLY HUNG A PORTRAIT IN HIS
HOME OF --
AND IT'S REALLY DOCTOR WHO
MASSACRED 29 PALESTINIANS IN
THE MOSQUE IN THE WEST BANK IN
1994 BEFORE BEING KILLED
HIMSELF.
ITAMAR BEN-GVIR LATER TWEETED
THAT YOU TAKE THE PORTRAIT
DOWN.
AND 2007, HE TOLD CNN THAT THE
HOLIEST MOST CONTESTED SITE IN
JERUSALEM, THE THIRD HOLIEST
SITE ISLAMIST FOR THE JEWS
ONLY.
>> THAT IS FOR THE JEWISH
PEOPLE, NOT FOR THE ISLAMIC
PEOPLE, MECCA, MEDINA, WE HAD
THE TEMPLE.
>> THAT SENIOR, HE WAS
CONVICTED FOR INCITING ANTI
ARAB RACISM AND SUPPORTING
TERRORISM.
IN 2020, HIS SIGHTS TURNED TO
POLITICS, WINNING A SEAT IN
2021 ON A PLATFORM THAT
INCLUDED ANNEXING THE WEST BANK,
RELAXING THE MILITARY OPENED
FIRE POLICY AGAINST PALESTINIAN
RIOTERS AND POSTED THAT THE 24
TERRACE.
HE HAS SPENT HIS TIME IN
PARLIAMENT CHECKING THE
SPOTLIGHT FROM STUNTS LIKE
PULLING A GUN ON A CLASH
BETWEEN ISRAELIS AND
PALESTINIANS IN EAST JERUSALEM,
TELLING POLICE TO SHOOT ARABS
AND DOORSTONES.
TO BEING FORCIBLY REMOVED FROM
THE FLOOR OF THESE EARLY
PARLIAMENT, CALLING A FELLOW
MEMBER THE LEADER OF THE ARAB
MOVEMENT PARTY, WHO IS ALSO AN
ISRAELI CITIZEN, A TERRACE, SO
HE DIDN'T BELONG IN ISRAEL.
JUST LAST YEAR, NETANYAHU
HIMSELF DISMISSED THE IDEA OF
BEN GVIR LEADING A GOVERNMENT
MINISTRY.
A MINISTER?
NO, NOT IN MY GOVERNMENT.
BUT THIS YEAR, HIS TUNE
CHANGED.
ASKED AGAIN IF BEN GVIR WOULD
BE A MINISTER, HE ANSWERED, OF
COURSE YOU CAN BE.
--
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF THE
POLICE AS A MINISTER BEN GVIR,
THAT COULD AFFECT ISRAEL'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH ITS MOST
IMPORTANT ALLY, THE UNITED
STATES.
>> WE HOPE THAT ALL ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS WILL
CONTINUE TO SHARE THE VALUES OF
AN OPEN DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY,
INCLUDING TOLERANCE AND RESPECT
FOR ALL IN CIVIL SAUDI,
PARTICULARLY FOR MINORITY
GROUPS.
>> THE EXTREMISTS ONCE SHUNNED
FROM ISRAELI POLITICS NOW A